tell me you love dolly as much as I love
dolly from nine to five I love that
woman so much
I was exclusively with dolly in Boston
talking all things Christmas but I also
came bearing a little gift of my own a
very special et Friday flashback listen
to what I found from your first ever et
interview 1982 I do work hard but I like
to work and I will live it retire ah
that's true I'll never retire I feel
saying exactly I love to work the other
thing that I noticed in getting this
video was that Dolly Parton you've been
sexy longer than I've been alive well
thank you you're so gorgeous oh my god
what is the secret
oh lord I don't know just like I say I
don't know if I look that good always I
would say it's good gliding good makeup
and good doctors hard to imagine but
this gorgeous woman turns 74 next month
but she's working non-stop she appeared
at opening night of Dolly Parton's Smoky
Mountain Christmas Carol she's not in
the show but wrote the music for this
retelling of the Scrooge story inspired
by her childhood what do you think makes
this story in particular really special
because we grew up poor no one how it
was to have Christmas without money and
how you kind of just live on love and
and all the excitement so it was just
really was actually like a natural for
me three minutes
[Music]
dollie is headed back to Tennessee for
Christmas and I just had to know what's
gonna be on the dinner table we all have
to have that cornbread dressing and of
the ham and and chicken or turkey
whatever but I usually make a big pot of
chicken and dumplings cuz all my family
loves that I just love her so much and
if you're in the Boston area for the
holidays you can catch a Dolly Parton
Smoky Mountain Christmas Carol until
December 29 I'm so lucky I'm gonna be
there
[Music]